i think about
this stuff all the time so while i'm
paid to be an open source evangelist
scaling out applications is something
that i think about a lot i think about
it at various times and i have um this
guy here my son
leonard and
what's interesting is when he was one
and a half years old he was already
driving netflix on his own
and we could talk about users who get
upset when they can't play a video where
they can't order an item right but
there's nothing like a two-year-old who
can't watch his damn cartoons because
some database issue or some
architectural issue in the cloud and
this this didn't happen very often on
netflix
but it does happen occasionally he gets
really mad and equipment gets broken so
i care deeply about this for reasons
other than just my professional life and
the reality is this guy growing up from
his very first memories that he's going
to have as an adult being able to do
these use these online applications with
low latency he expects it to always work
24 7.
many of us in the room we remember the
old rotary phones or you know before we
we had a phone in our pocket you had the
entirety of mankind's knowledge of
fingertips
but
this guy
the generations growing up today
they aren't going to put up with
the failures that we've seen
so
our application architectures have
advanced a lot over the years
um you know people expect things to just
freaking work right nobody wants to dink
around and click through
and go through extra screens and find
errors and see 404s and understand what
a far off court means and go back and
try again this isn't going to cut it
right we all know this
um you know there's online applications
you know uh this is a screenshot from
final fantasy 14 which is a whole vastly
multiplayer online game these things are
doing
millions of transactions a second for
things like people training virtual
items and these people get really upset
when things go wrong
and the way that these applications are
built and spent a couple years at soe is
different from the way that we built
what built web applications at the time
even today we still build web
applications very often the way we did
10 15 years ago
and that needs to change
um you know so
the problem i'm looking at is when
everything's working great we have these
funneled architectures
they
it's all good but you need to design for
max capacity right if we design the
roads around here in the bay area
for
for the capacity to use overweight that
is what happened and look what we're
dealing with today
right now we've got this capacity
problem where we have all these people
that want to drive to their startups
from gilroy all the way out to san
francisco but the roads don't have the
capacity to do it and it's not it's not
a very great analogy but it is kind of
the what we're looking at if we don't
change the way we're building and
designing applications
so a little bit about the evolution of
application architecture um just going
to step through a few of these real
quick
we have the classic
client server
this is long dead it still happens
occasionally there's still some legacy
stuff out there that does it maybe some
people remember
when there were just terminals that
connected to the mainframe or the
database and it was a direct connection
from the fat client either on a
workstation or a terminal to the
database software
and that worked fine throughout the 80s
and part of the 90s but eventually we
moved on because it didn't scale we
moved to the three-tier architecture
right the red dots are clients
up at the top
the blue dots are the application server
and we have this big cylinder at the
bottom which is just any old database
right it could be oracle mysql i don't
care
it's all pretty much the same it's a
funnel-shaped architecture
at the end of the day you just lose you
lose capacity as that funnel
and then there's
the funnel fee or bottleneck or whatever
you like to call it
so ruby on rails is a great example of a
funneled architecture there's a database
at the bottom of the whole thing nearly
every web application in your existence
is still targets this architecture first
and i don't think that's necessary
anymore and as you have things like this
on or out there today it makes even less
sense because now your database cannot
scale your application
so we keep going with this right we can
have master slave replication at the
database level my skill is great at this
postgres can do it
oracle has a couple options around rack
is essentially looks like this because
when you're running rack
you still have the cylinder on the
bottom it's just one level lower your
arachno's and here's the big emc array
right here your symmetrics where your hp
um super uh xp 12 000 or whatever that
their modern array is
and you still have that funnel there
right
and you can add cache and stuff but
really what you're doing is you're
papering over a problem is that your
application architecture isn't built to
be able to handle the throughput of all
of your clients
all the way through the stack right and
the deeper you scale your stack the
easier things are at when you have load
spikes not always on the end whatever
tier is being overloaded you can scale
up horizontally
your database can scale up your app tier
can scale out and your clients can keep
just adding clients you don't hit that
limit where you have clients coming on
and then you run out of capacity and
then you stop getting clients not only
because they can't log into your service
because they don't want to deal with the
of having a broken service
so this is kind of
how i like to see things today right i
think a new number of guys are out many
ways in order
um
and you know we have a cassandra ring in
the middle
we have our applications here then we
have lots and lots and lots of clients
and right keeps stealing i've built this
and deployed these applications i was at
uyala we have lots of our customers that
are building this way now where they're
building
they'll build a cassandra cluster
they'll have a yarn tier or amazon or a
huge docker infrastructure for deploying
or horizontally scaling their app
architecture and that's easier because
they don't have to worry as much about
what solid did their database
which is by definition harder to move
around it has weight it has data
right
and now we can scale further
on every single tier because now all the
tiers can scale horizontally
and then
things go really well right and then
your client look doubles and triples
again but we can keep scaling the whole
infrastructure all the way down we don't
have to keep buying bigger boxes and
going back to hp for another superdome
or whatever it is
we come to the cost because now we've
moved
what we've given up is the database
isn't handling every single
transaction around our data for us
anymore
right it used to be that you do insert
into update table
but you can still do the same operations
but you've got to think about
consistency a lot of you we're here for
christos talk about eventual consistency
he's probably talked i didn't get to
come in but
um
you know i've i've known christops for a
while and you have to start thinking
about do i actually need consistency
here a lot of times the answer is
and then for when you do we'll come to
that we can still do it with cassandra
and it scales in a different way but
mostly what this talk is about is how do
you think about these problems in such a
way that you can ride the right
architectures
that looks like a jellyfish
yeah you could call that one
so what i'm really here to talk about
isn't
network diagrams and
funky architectures it's how do we think
about applications beyond
where the read modify write cycle
happens right rather than sticking all
of the read modify right down into the
database here which is easy and
convenient
it needs to be throughout the tier right
we're looking at
this one's similar
we can do them here we have lightweight
transactions in cassandra 2.0
so you can do fully consistent
transactions at the databases here but
that has a scalability limit because
these are more expensive nodes right and
they have more and more gravity to the
more data moving that data around is
expensive
so we need to move some of that logic
out to our applications here and even
sometimes you'll see this happening out
of the clients here right if you have a
mobile application
it's gathering a whole bunch of data it
might actually do some of the mutations
directly in the client security problems
aside people still do it and there are
still cases where it makes sense
this certainly makes sense so far
so
what we want to talk about in terms of
this is practical safety around how do
we build data models
to support these architectures
we've actually consistency which you've
already heard a lot about so i won't
over overdo it
um
different kinds of demos i'll talk a
little bit about overwriting so
cassandra has the ability of because of
the way pop starts work rather than
doing mutation necessarily you can do a
lot of things where you overwrite the
same cell over and over and over and
this it has some side effects but it is
a valid way to avoid a lot of problems
um key value
journal or time series style data
collection types um content adjustable
storage which is kind of more esoteric
but it's a useful example to know about
and then finally i'll talk about
lightweight transactions for when you
need the database to handle this for you
and so
one of one of the things that changes
when you move to an eventually
consistent model is
you'll hear a lot of people talking
about how you need to have a
mathematical proof of cap theorem or you
need to prove that your system can do
xyz
but this is the quote that i always
think of when people tell me this right
is we've all built applications without
going jack about all these mathematical
proofs for these things and they all
work just fine
the reason why is
we're modeling it sometimes in our heads
without actually knowing the math but
also there's this problem of the
disconnect between theory and practice
so some of these things are
not good ideas but they're interesting
to know about because they'll help you
arrive at
um so
you know some of this comes down to
safety
when you take all the safety off right
you forget testing and you just slap out
some code and throw it out there you can
do it really fast you can do some quick
and cool stuff right
but you know
when i set your pants on fire
i hear that's unpleasant i haven't
experienced it myself
you can you can do a little better right
we can build a dangerous system and then
that looks dangerous on the surface
and this here is my favorite is the
rocket on the back of the car but you
know this thing has a roll gauge in it
the driver is there's a five point
harness installed in the driver's seat
and the driver is wearing a fire
retardant suit a helmet and gloves
there's a lot of different ways to
mitigate
failure
besides just building everything to well
the japanese standard right
so this is the shinkansen just cruises
at
320 kilometers an hour it's almost 200
miles an hour that train moves and the
amount that they spend on making these
safe and the amount of effort it takes
to keep the rails smooth and to make
sure that all the curves are done right
is incredible it's an incredible amount
of work we can't do that in our daily
jobs most of the time
most we don't have the time we don't
have the resources so we kind of
so when i'm talking about these
different architectures
that's what i'm going to be thinking
about is some of these are kind of crazy
content addressable storage isn't that
useful in practice although you almost
all of you use it every day because
that's how git works
um
but when you're thinking about this and
you're moving out and you're doing these
these mutations in your applications
here not to get too
fed or too tied up in the theory
of how to do it right because you're not
going to get the job done
so
read modify right
do you everybody i understand
let me take a poll how many people know
what i mean when i say read modify write
cycle
awesome okay
good this is good material
so i want to do a mutation on a record
so what happens is
i want to go and say i get promoted
right patrick decides he wants to go
back out in the field and now there's an
open spot for chief evangelist
and i have security so they promote me
it's not going to happen
and i can't my hair doesn't stand up
like that
so i can't have the job anyway
um
so we need to update my ring in the
company
from three to four and we need to update
the last
promotion date because of course we
would track all promotions because you
can't remote people too fast this is a
corporate world right
so to read modify right what i mean is
is in order to mutate that record we
have to read the old record off of
storage
up the main memory and my skill is doing
this oracle's on this everybody has to
do this to mutate records you pull the
data structure off of storage it could
be on disk it could be a memory it
doesn't really matter right
you make the changes to that data
structure
and then you write it back to disk
so you read you modify it you write it
if it's redis it's all in memory if it's
oracle it's really complicated if it's
cassandra
it's the same thing right we read it off
of disk you actually read it in your
application most of the time you do the
mutation you write
now everybody knows what refont
flywright is right
awesome
so this is the thing i want you to be
thinking about when you're building your
applications
if you think about it in terms of
whenever you're doing updates or inserts
and you want to make a change
where is this read modify right
happening in my infrastructure where
what server layer is it going to happen
at and that big ring is it's probably
not happening on your client devices
because there's a security nightmare
there there's no way to tell devices you
don't control are going to do with the
data
um so it's probably going to happen in
your applications here
because we don't have stored procedures
or anything like that that's that's
long dead architecture i hope
um
so
but when we go into the distributed
systems world it introduces a new
problem right on a single node
we have cpu instructions that will take
care of locking for us for example or we
have atomic comparing swap
but when you go to distribute system
there's you have to have a consistent
view of what the data is at any given
point in time
and so when i do this mutation and i
talk to one node in the database
and that node fails during the
transaction before it's replicated off
that node we got a problem
so we have tools to deal with that right
because
generally this isn't a problem
because what happens is before this this
right is returned back to the client
it's going to replicate it so that's one
thing to remember is your client will
throw an error if there's a failure in
the middle of the transaction and you
will get an exception back
so it's safe to do these out inside your
applications here is kind of what i'm
getting at where it used to be you know
your dba would tell you oh use stored
procedures for all of your business
logic because then it's in the database
and all the consistency is managed there
well that doesn't scale because now all
that code is running on one node
or a small group of nodes and you can't
scale it as easily because now you have
to scale your database which means you
have to scale your data or your storage
systems and expensive qualified hardware
solutions
so a quick explanation of what i mean by
very fire right and then on to data
models
so overwriting is an interesting use
case i'm going to just cover a quick one
that i've done before i was working on a
monitoring system
and one of its key features key
requirements was is it needed to able to
support instances in ec2 that came and
went hundreds a day right
um
kind of similar to netflix's not quite
as aggressive
but we would spin up you know a new
cluster of 16 machines and they would
enter into the monitoring system and
start dumping data in and then two days
later they might be gone replaced by
other nodes and they're cycling really
fast this didn't used to happen
10 years ago
you built
25 boxes to run the applications here
and you left them sit there and that was
it if you added more you would add like
five more and you'd configure them and
put stuff on them and it was no big deal
the monitoring system didn't have to
care how fast nodes were coming in and
going
so
host names used to be how we addressed
all those systems in that day but today
it doesn't make any damn sense at all
because these nodes are changing so much
the host names have no meaning at all so
we needed to apply some kind of id or
some surrogate key to the systems that
allowed us to address them across all
these iterations
but now we have a problem because people
because humans want to talk to host
names and all of our tools want to talk
to host names and id addresses so we
needed an index that we could use
that would tie the guide back to
hostname so this is common in a lot of
applications that you're probably
working on especially with cassandra
so
we didn't want to have to write like
some demon that basically would go and
do the mutations right so one option
would be to have a service
and a node could register with that
service and go and say hey i have to do
it blah blah blah and here is all my
data and please go and update my record
and it would go and read it from the
database update the record and write it
back
but why would we bother doing that first
read it doesn't matter
right this is kind of one of the lessons
of big data
maybe we just write a new record every
time
well after a while that would kind of
waste a lot of space so what we did is
we created a time series schema
whereas the daily bucket for these
indexes so on any given day you can pull
back that index you get all the hosts
for that it wasn't that big it's like 25
megabytes or something
and instead of mutating records in there
we just every hour that node would send
the same registration information every
hour
all the same stuff and we just write it
into the database never read it only the
clients ever read it so the the nodes
generating the data had no clue what was
being held in the database hollow
and the service that was actually
updating the records never actually read
those records either it just wrote
everybody with me
has anybody ever tried this before
cool cool
so you learn this good
so
so what you would do is instead of you
would look up and you take that position
and you the daily bucket's easy to
compute
and you just go and you get your record
you serialize it right into the database
boom done never read it on the server
side and then when a client wants to
know that information then you finally
read it but you don't have to care
because if you overwrite it 100 times
throughout the day or 24 times it just
doesn't matter
this has one big downside
we've completely avoided three modifier
right cycles throughout our architecture
for the right and on the read side you
don't have to worry about blocking or
anything
but
the the what to watch out for is this is
not good for a high throughput solution
in a lot of ways because whether you end
up with is a compaction problem
where what's happening is when you do a
lot of overrides
you can end up splitting that that row
your partitions will end up getting
split over many ss tables especially if
you're on lcs so you write the record an
hour later the map table has been
flushed
i thought i had a screen for that
so the meta table gets flushed to disk
and then maybe another one does the
compaction require another one and then
finally when you want to do these reads
now you have to read all of those ss
tables to find the most recent record
and then when the action comes along
to take them all and merge them and put
it back down into a smaller ss table
which causes io so if you're doing a lot
of overwrites it can cause problems with
compaction but for
simple cases like this it's not even
worth thinking about just do it
uh another one is key value
so cassandra is just buying key value
the um the core oss developers like
center hated when i say this because
they don't want to be a key value store
and it's not a great key value store
it's just a good key value store
so i say use cassandra for key value
when you've already got conservative
deployed your application's already
connected to it and you have some key
value data you want to manage throw them
in a table because
it'd be done
you don't have to worry about
synchronizing memcache keys
replication's taken care of it's all
basically happening in memory there's
one little trick you can do but if you
just sit if it's
mostly ephemeral data you can turn off
durability on the schema and that saves
you a little bit of i on the commit line
so in general this is more of a utility
thing you got a little
bunch of brand new data you want to
store
this is a nice little pattern
what this does though is it forces the
read modify right off into your
application just like that cash key does
right
there's no same way to do that in the
database here well you could use lwt but
that would be just for consistency
and then this is kind of our bright and
butter
data model how many people went to
patrick's data modeling session
so it's not totally very cool
so this is kind of the simplest time
series data model i can come up with
we have
the time bucket which looks kind of like
this the second one down here
the uh
so you take the date and you truncate it
down to some arbitrary time it's not
arbitrary actually it's some easily
calculated aligned time so you'll end up
five minutes one hour one day nothing
bigger than a day it really makes sense
right
how many people can define a week in
programmatic terms and teach a computer
what a week is
it's not easy
it's not easy it's a lot of work
and it's incredibly computationally
expensive and the worst part is it's not
a technical problem it's a political
problem
right time is defined by politics
at least wall clock type this
leap seconds are a political body that
that says when these seconds happen
daylight savings time i mean
i
if i ever got to meet benjamin franklin
i would like to smack him for that
so
we have our time bucket so like i said
one hour is great one day depending on
if it's low
a relatively small amount of data one
day bucket makes sense one minute
sometimes makes sense and even
occasionally one second if it's really
really high throughput
not very often right you know usually
one minute
so most of the stuff we did in this
monitoring system was five minutes and
24 hours
the next one is the actual time
right so the time bucket ends up being
your partition key
and then the time is how you do next
that's basically if you're you know the
old threat model that would be your
column key
right
and then whatever you want in the volume
i said blog here you know you could
throw a bunch of json in there we don't
really like it when we store json in
there but it works
um but you could have a whole
extended table there with a whole bunch
of attributes right it doesn't matter
this is the simplest thing to work
and then inserting your data looks like
this
and that's a simple time series data
model cassandra is really really good at
time series and the thing is is
you can model a lot of things as time
series that you don't realize this time
series
right like i was just talking about host
information you have 10 000 servers in
your network
and you if you decide to instead of
having just a table of hosts with 10 000
entries in it if you had a daily table
or
bucket of host information now all of a
sudden you have this nice convenient
snapshot of your network every day for
free
and what we found was is that was useful
over time
people would come and say
hey
how many kills did we go through last
month
well i'll just flip through the host
table and go back and i can actually go
and grab the guise and i can try them
back and get the instance types and all
that stuff from the monitoring system
because i have the last six months of
daily snapshots of what our inventory is
so it's interesting to think about that
especially when you're working with time
series a lot of things will fit into a
time series schema that don't
necessarily up the front
up front look like time series data
and you got to think about in terms of
snapshots right if you use zfs snapshots
occasionally you get that same effect
for free
because you can go roll back and say
what did that look like six months ago
um
so
this is kind of useful for whiteboards i
like throw this in and this is another
one i get in trouble with the uh the
core people when i when i do it
um
especially this one here
we'll start here so this is kind of
another way to kind of draw the what a
time series schema looks like sometimes
it's hard to imagine to model in your
head what what your data actually looks
like so i like to give ways to think
about this or to visualize it
so we have the same data right there's
our bucket timestamp there's some data
maybe it's json or something
and what happens is when it gets stored
this is actually kind of how it looks
when it's actually stored on disk
because arnold will store
especially time series data where time
is a key we'll store that data in sorted
order on disk
it actually does it for memory too
this is really useful because you can do
things like single sync access to a
window of time
right and you can do tech you can do
range queries across
and this kind of makes it easier to see
that so when you do a range where you
want to go from point a to point b
but this also ends up being a single
seek out disc when you're going to disc
and you go and say give me this slice
inside this partition
because it's all stored in sorted order
cassandra knows exactly where that data
is and can instruct the operating system
to go in and get exactly those blocks of
data that it needs which is very
efficient
the second one is kind of i use this for
whiteboarding because hundred data
models
this is from the old the battle days of
thrift
but it's still useful when you're
talking about the storage side of things
and cassandra and performance
is this kind of nested map
so if you when i'm drawing a whiteboard
i'm trying to do in the model with
somebody i'll actually do that you know
open that here's my partition key you
know and if i'm doing a compound
partition key i'll just put some kind of
stuff real like pipes or something and
then use the fat arrow and then more
maps so i'm not going to talk about that
a lot but just kind of keep that in mind
when you're thinking about data models
and whiteboarding them this is a little
more useful sometimes than you know er
style diagrams
content addressable storage
so this one's really interesting i think
there's going to be more to content
adjustable storage in the future but the
big one that everybody uses every day
pretty much is git so that's how get get
achieves its speed and a lot of that's
why you see these funky hash values for
version ids instead of
integers like to use it from subversion
or other
cps
so all they do is content addressable
storage says that the address of my
content
is
determined by the content
so git uses sha-1 checksums which are
cryptographically mostly almost secure
been broken a couple times
um
it could be an mp5
for now cassandra uses like the murmur
three is actually a good good algorithm
for this kind of thing so you just take
your payload
just up through the code right here
so this is just a little bit of ruby um
this right here is red so i don't forget
to tell you that this is a terrible
thing to do this will not work in
production
because it has no guaranteed ordering so
you can get different order different
you'll get different addresses each time
but it's just the shortest way to show a
serialization of the fitness lockout
so we're going to use sha1
we connect with cql we connect to we say
we have a key space to find this
and
then we
create a data structure in ruby so this
is not to do with the center yet
we take a checksum of that data after
it's serialized this could be you know
json
encode
or protocol buffers or whatever
um generally cassandra you're not going
to do that very often if you're storing
pause that's how you would do it and
then we just take and we get the text
string for that checksum
right
and then that becomes our content id so
if we want to get the same content back
we're going to query our content id
equal this checksum right
give me some hack stream that's 36
characters
um so for inserting content we're going
to insert into
kaz
value
you know this is our content id
now
this has some downsides right you have
to maintain a lot of indexes to be able
to actually get to your data afterwards
because it's essentially random ids
they're hard to predict without actually
having the data but the way git does is
it just generates these lists of shas if
you look inside the dot get directory
you'll see these like um
master or your current branch there's
just a little text file on dot get slash
i think capital head and it'll just be
the shock the file
and all it does when it wants to know
that it just reads that file the whole
thing and then it's got it and your your
file tree is actually just a big long
list of these shops
in the history as well
so
those are a few models that don't
actually require a read modifier eggs
get worked out but at the end of the day
we've been programming with sql
databases for some cases i've been doing
it for 15 years
some of you have probably been doing it
for 20 plus
i'm not going to appoint anybody
and some people may have for a couple
years but if you're in university and
you're learning about databases you
probably need some kind of sql database
so you're used to being able to do this
in the database and sometimes it's just
you just want to get the job done and
you want to use it so that's why we have
lightweight transactions now in
cassandra
but library transactions aren't the only
way
so another way is with our collection
clips
the maps and sets in consumer are crdt
they're safe to modify modified
without locking
so you can do inserts and updates into
sets and maps without any locking and
they're fully consistent
a lot of people don't realize that
so this example um
that's my dog
he's a puppy he's really stupid um
and so i was talking to my japanese
teacher and i said
yeah there's a phrase i use from my
house a lot a lot i say
you know
which is basically a stupid dog
or if you know
you see how stupid my dog is
um and it turns out that doesn't
translate to japanese at all
because
she just looked at me funny and she said
stupid dog
yeah he's you know stupid dog like you
just say you mean if you're diagnosed
apparently that's not a thing outside of
america or at least western world so um
anyway i'm going to use this example
because this is uh
to me
so
um
i want to have a set of authors and tags
i don't need to be able to have multiple
entries with the same same key so i can
have the math success i can add authors
remove authors all these things it's
fully consistent i don't have to think
about it
same kind of thing for maps maps are
basically like maps that you expect in
java or python dictionaries or whatever
they behave in a very similar way and
they're
cheap and easy to modify you don't have
to think a lot about consistency
then there's lightweight transactions
everybody heard about lightweight
transactions you know what they are
great
real quick looks like they're running
out of time
what it is is cassandra has now an
ability to do things in the back end so
that when you do a transaction when
you're making a change to the database
you can set these little clauses this if
using any gold redness or if not exist
here
and it will actually do multiple wrong
paxos to make sure that all the nodes in
the transaction agree on the value
before it returns the commit back to
your client and if any one of those
known is out of sync will return an
error to you
so you always know that the data that
you that you committed now will go to
disk and it'll be exactly what you
expected and this is guaranteed by the
database now again
the downside it's a lot slower than all
the other stuff i've talked about
because now it has to do it has to talk
to all those nodes in place so if you're
on r equal three all three of those
nodes have to agree and report back to
the coordinator that they agree which
requires multiple round trips on the
network so realize this is for like the
one two percent of your application
where this is absolutely necessary you
should be using every other possible
technique when you don't absolutely need
this
we can talk more about lightweight
transactions up outside
a lot of time
but
you know in conclusion
we're scaling further faster than ever
your application architecture the
three-tiered architecture isn't going to
get us there
and you need to think more about
everything every level of your tier
scaling out
wide
because moore's law has failed us pretty
much at this point it might pick up
again but we can only shrink the process
so far
and barring another big jump in cpu
technology we're not going to get bigger
boxes again for a really long time
so
think about where those mutations are
happening and strategically place them
and it's more important than
where you play than a lot of the other
factors that maybe you think about
before right what library am i going to
use blah blah blah what kind of servers
think about first where is mutation
happening and then let that drive a lot
of your other decisions
how many application servers how many
database servers what kind of network am
i sitting on how many availability zones
am i going to be in those are the things
that you can drive thinking about where
is the mutation going to happen
any questions if we have time do we have
time
i think we have like three minutes
why don't the marketing guys call it
lightweight if it's like two extra reads
and it's really heavyweight
it is and i think it's because the
syntax is very lightweight
i mean we call it a lot of different
things internally um
lgbt is kind of what we call them
and they are a lot lighter in terms of
um in terms of cassandra they're very
happy but in terms of distributed
systems in general they're actually
fairly light right doing distributed
transactions in general is usually very
very expensive and we've gotten this
cheap if we can it'll probably get a
little faster in the future
so it's a slightly class
just as long as we can do this
well thank you very much